agathe et mathieu regardé hier soir en
fin d'émission
j'avais posé une question à nabila ce
qui est presque elle serait prête à
revenir dans l'émission agathe vous êtes
pour vous aimez mathieu vous n'aimez pas
votre petite pancarte
j'aime j'aime pas regarder sur le moment
nabila ma chérie est ce que je serai
prête à revenir dans tpm paix à la
rentrée j'ai très envie que tu reviennes
oui franchement bon c'est vrai que
touche par an passé une expérience que
je n'ai pas pu terminer que j'ai
vaguement goûter et donc
donc c'est un exercice qui me plaît j'ai
pas mal d'autres activités mais je pense
revenir
ouais
[Applaudissements]
alors agathe vous êtes pour oui je sais
pour absolument je le mets le 30 il aime
beaucoup nabila deux arguments très
simple le premier c'est que ce talk-show
qui est le plus regardé par les jeunes
tpm paix ne peut pas se permettre de
n'avoir que des chroniqueurs de plus de
40 autour de la table vous dites par des
swaps non mais ça ça va et c'est pas une
vie sauve également
moi j'ai 26 ans mais on est on est en
minorité il ya que maxime guény kelly et
moi qui sommes représentants de cette
génération et nabila est la parfaite
représentante de cette génération de
jeunes elle a absolument compris la
société ses codes ses dérivés elle
s'insère part confiant bien bas excuse
moi mais habile heures représentent que
2 2e deuxième argument c'est qu'elle n'a
fait qu'une quinzaine je crois des
missions dans la saison 2014-2015 tout
le monde se rappelle de son passage et
si elle a marqué l'émission de sa
personnalité elle apporte énormément de
fraîcheur et tout le monde sait qu'une
bande se repose sur la personnalité de
ses chroniqueurs et aucun autour de la
table nat la personnalité kabila dont je
pense que c'est une véritable plus-value
merci mon coeur deux arguments nul alors
moi alors je t'aime tient le 4 mai au
vote un petit peu sincère qu'est ce
qu'on va chercher quand on va chercher
nabila une ancienne animatrice non
l'avis d'un ancien producteur non la vie
de la jeunesse la vie de la star de la
télé réalité et sun genre médias qui
organise la balade un expert médias nom
de quelqu'un qui amène d un fonds qui
fait une enquête non absolument qu'elles
soient là mais non mais qu'est ce qu'on
va chercher en fait on va chercher une
jolie bimbo et on va rire un peu à ses
dépens parce qu'elle va sortir des
phrases totalement aberrante parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans la culture du
delà de la deûle à gérer pas de la
bêtise des décomplexée mais aujourd'hui
c'est ça pourrit des gens à ses dépens
de croire quelqu'un et on a peut-être
qui dira ben en fait ici mes poissons
ils ont et sans vision ben en fait si
quand tu manger un kebab c'était un
animal voilà ça vous amuse ça c'est ce
qu'on veut dans l'émission est d'un
niveau de l'émission hiwar essaâ c'est
pathétique et même pour elle c'est
triste parce qu'en fait on rit à ses
dépens en question
ce qu'est la même alors qu'elle amène l
arène un autre genre de télé c'est là
c'est la star de la télé réalité ça
c'est la plus grande star y en aura pas
une autre série noire mais si jolie et
bien la télé réalité c'est un jour qui
représentait en télévision et on s'est
dit si il doit avoir quelqu'un
téléralité autour de la table c'est la
star et c'est vrai que nabila et
lacenaire alors au moins six personnes
serrées au moins sur usenet sur un truc
quoi vos stars de réalité l'arrêter ou
part elle serait pas hyper jolie et
bimbo elle serait pas nous les médecins
n'ont pas du tout on n'est pas du tout
alors là vous des métis alain kalala une
personnalité mes examens très très rare
skate je sais même pas si on a presque l
élection allait lui laisser à ses dépens
pour rigoler non j'aime j'aime pas au
bout de vos titres banca alors autour de
nabila même des pmp augustine comme ça
c'est pas toi en fait moi j'y suis pas
d'accord tu envie de voir moi je moi je
trouve qu'elle est très joli à voir
après je sais pas si elle intéressante à
écouter alors eh bien ça c'est bon ça